frustrated relatives wait outside a
hospital in Ginny's capital Conakry
desperate for news and when the bodies
of their loved ones will be released we
came today to collect the bodies but the
Ministry of Health says they're not
ready to be released the families have
been mourning for 14 days we want them
to give us the bodies for burial the 11
protesters were killed earlier this
month during one of a number of
demonstrations against president Alfa
conde thousands of people have been
marching through the city week after
week angry about a possible
constitutional change that they say will
push Guinea into a dictatorship they
accused president Conde of wanting to
hold on to power for a third term for
them ten years of Condes government is
enough 81 year old Conde first came to
power in 2010 it was Ginny's first
democratic election after more than 50
years of mostly military rule since its
independence from France in 1958 former
leaders are worried about the future of
Guinea under conde I don't have the
words to express myself this deception
but what are we seeing on the ground it
could kill politics in Guinea a funeral
is sacred in our tradition our younger
brothers were killed how can the family
come here 14 days later with no chance
to have the funeral earlier the Ministry
of Health says the delay in releasing
the bodies is because it's pathologists
haven't finished performing autopsies
which it says will help uncover the real
causes and circumstances of their loved
ones deaths these relatives have no
faith in that process and they insist
the government is making an already
difficult situation even worse Victoria
Gaytan B al-jazeera